في باكستان حيث تناول وطهي البصل من ابرز
طقوس مائده الطعام الا انه بات سلعه ثمينه
تضاهي طيب الفواكه والخضار كغيرها من
العديد من دول العالم فقير محمد يعمل في
زراعه البصل منذ نحو خمسه عقود لكنه بات
يشتكي ضيق العيش وقله الحيله
اوضاعنا خلال العامين الماضيين بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار البذور والسماد المبيدات
والوقود وفواتير الكهرباء عند بيع
محاصيلنا لا نحصل سوى على ربع سعر السوق
حيث يقوم التجار بتخزينها ثم رفع الاسعار
دون اي رقابه حكوميه لا استطيع تامين
المصاريف لاسره واشعر ان عملي لم يعد
مجديا
حالوا فقير محمد حال الكثير من المزارعين
في باكستان الذين يشتكون ارتفاع تكاليف
الانتاج ان بعضهم يعول على استمرار ارتفاع
اسعار البصل حتى موسم الحصاد الصيف المقبل
بل ضاعف من مساحه الحقول المخصصه لزرعته
املا في تحسين اوضاعه رغم المخاطر
اضافه تكاليف الانتاج في السابق كنا
نسترجع ما انفقناه وما تبقى نصرف على
انفسنا حاليا اسعار البصل مرتفعه لكننا لا
نعلم ماذا سيحصل في الموسم الحصاد فاذا
انخفضت الاسعار الى النصف فهذا يعني اننا
سنخسر
ويتراوح سعر كيلو البصل في باكستان حول
دولار امريكي حسب بعد المنطقه عن مراكز
الانتاج والتوزيع فيما شحوا انتاج البصل
وقله توفره دفع باكستان الاستيراد باقي
احتياجاتها من الخارج
لقد تضرر محصول اقليم السند الاكثر
والاسرع انتاجا للبصل بسبب الفيضانات وما
ينتج حاليا بالكاد يغطي ربع طلب السوق اما
الباقي فنستورده من مصر والهند وتركيا لذا
فالاسعار باهضه بسبب الضرائب وكلفه الشحن
والنقل
وادت الفيضانات العارمات التي شهدتها
باكستان الصيف الماضي الى اتلاف الالاف من
الاراضي الزراعيه كما ان الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه زادت من تكاليف الوقود والمواد
الزراعيه كل ذلك عوامل ساهمت في انخفاض
الانتاج وزياده الطلب وارتفاع اسعار البصل
الى جانب ما خلفته الفيضانات من اضرار
بالمحاصيل الزراعيه في باكستان ومن بينها
البصل يعزم مراقبون ارتفاع اسعاره عالميا
الى زياده كلفه الوقود والاسمده والاحتكار
والتلاعب الاسعار عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه مقاطعه تبتر